-[ Laughing ]
Intricate already.
-[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Let's see if I get an aura
off it.
I know what it is.
I feel it. Yeah.
-[ As Donald Trump ]
Jimmy, it's a burrito.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Alec and I are about to face
off in a game of Box of Lies.
Now, here's how it works.
Upstage are a bunch of boxes
containing objects
neither of us have seen before.
Taking turns,
we're going to select a box
and open it
on our side of the table,
out of the view
of the other person.
You must remove the object from
the box, show it
to the audience,
then look at your opponent and
tell them what's in your box.
[ Laughter ]
They have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
Alec, why don't you
pick the first box?
Go for it, buddy.
Any number, any one.
[ Audience shouting ]
And just -- Yeah,
you pick it up.
Ooh, that's already a hint.
It's very light.
Ooh.
Okay. Ooh, it's very heavy,
maybe.
These are all hints.
-[ Normal voice ] I'm exhausted
already.
-[ Laughs ] All right.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-I just rip it? Let's do it?
-Alec,
what is in your --
what is in your box?
What was in your box?
-In my box was a very thick,
red, gelatinous teddy bear
swaddled in a blanket
with a binky in its mouth.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-You're good.
Pretty good, Baldwin.
Almost too good.
That is a lie!
-Eat this, Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Ahh! I just -- I just believe --
I just --
All right, all right.
Which one here?
[ Audience shouting ]
4.
♪♪
Oof.
[ Grunting ]
[ Exhales sharply ]
[ Box thuds ]
[ Breathes heavily ]
-Good acting.
-[ Breathing heavily ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
♪♪
[ Sighs ]
If we don't get
the Emmy this year...
[ Laughter ]
...we've done something
horribly wrong.
Uh...
-What was in the box, Jimmy?
-[ Chuckles ]
In my box...
is what I assume to be
shavings of a pickle...
...in the shape of a welcome
mat -- a tiny welcome mat --
for possibly a dollhouse.
Could be shavings of...
I think it's pickle.
And the word that's written
on the mat, it says,
"Irmagard, welcome."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I say you are a liar!
-Ha ha! You got me!
Oh, my God!
-Aah!
What is it?
-It's weird, right?
It's like olive --
pimento olives
with, like, a hand
with a ring on it.
I don't know what --
I don't know what it is, man.
-It's like a surgical glove
filled with olives.
-It is -- [ As Donald Trump ]
It's the grossest thing
I've ever seen
in my entire life.
-[ Clears throat ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
Grab a box, and tell me
what's in your box.
[ Audience shouting ]
-[ Normal voice ] Oh, my God!
I can tell it's light.
Oh, my gosh.
-I got to do that good acting
I just saw a minute ago.
-I can tell that it's light.
Ooh. Okay.
-It's a box of Tic Tacs.
Here we go.
-Uh-huh.
[ Sighs ]
♪♪
[ Laughing ]
Intricate already.
-[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Let's see if I get an aura
off it.
I know what it is.
I feel it. Yeah.
-[ As Donald Trump ]
Jimmy, it's a burrito.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Slaps desk ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
-It's a really big, fat, juicy
burrito filled with bananas.
It's a banana burrito.
-[ As Donald Trump ] Can I ask
where this burrito is from?
-It's a big, fat, juicy
banana burrito from Honduras.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not a juicy burrito
from China, is it?
-No, no. I myself would not
ever eat a burrito from China.
[ Laughter ]
And the Honduran that delivered
this burrito here to the studio,
we had him deported.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good idea.
That sounds like a good idea.
[ Inhales sharply ]
[ Normal voice ] It's a burrito
filled with bananas.
A banana burrito.
You know what?
Absolutely not.
You lie, my friend.
-[ Normal voice ]
What makes you say that, Jimmy?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's still the champ!
Alec Baldwin.
Blake and I
are about to face off
in a game called Box of Lies.
Now, here's how it works.
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out the object,
describe it to your opponent.
They have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
Blake, why don't you
pick the first...box?
-I feel like I'm on
"The Price is Right."
That was so exciting.
Okay, I take it first?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right. Already,
it looks pretty light.
Could have pretended
it was heavy,
but you didn't. Yeah.
Well, all right.
♪♪
-Oh, Lord, have mercy.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
What I have in my hands here --
-Yeah. What do you have
in your hands there?
-It's milky.
There's some soggy,
rainbow-y chunks in here.
It's a milky, soggy,
rainbow-y, chunky --
-This is how
you describe something?
This is how you describe
something real
that's in front of you?
-Time-telling device.
-Oh? Time-telling device?
-Mm-hmm.
-Now, that would only mean one
thing to me, a watch, perhaps?
-Mm-hmm.
-What else could tell time,
a sundial?
-Mm-hmm, yeah, a sundial.
What are you, like,
an ancient Greek?
-Yeah, well, a time-telling
device? Who says that?
I think that you're lying.
I do not believe
that that is what you have.
You are -- That is a lie.
-Do I win if you got it right,
or do I win if --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-To be honest -- To be honest,
I just forgot for a second.
[ Laughter ]
You -- No, if I get it right,
you lose.
-That I was lying?
-Yes.
-Oh, I want to take it back.
-No!
-Wait.
-Wait, what?
Oh, wait.
You did win.
Oh, my gosh. You won.
That was --
[ Dinging ]
Oh. No, I saw
what you did there.
That was a very odd description,
a very odd description.
-The weirdest game
I've ever played.
-She did have that.
You're right. It's an odd game.
-Who makes these things up?
-Dude, we --
All right. All right.
[ Audience shouting
indistinctly ]
Someone just screamed, "3! 3!"
She's yelling "3." All right.
Here we go. Here we go.
All right.
-Oh, God.
-Oh, my goodness.
[ Gasping ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I'd say it's --
It's funny.
-Mm-hmm.
-It's funny.
It's funny that you're here.
-Mm-hmm.
-'Cause it's a paperweight.
[ Laughter ]
It's got a head on it.
It's like a very weighted
weight.
Brass, I'd say,
a mixture of metals.
-Mm-hmm.
-In the brass variety.
-Unlacquered brass or --
-Yeah, it's a matte.
-A matte brass?
-Two T's and an E, matte finish.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-And then, there's
a Deadpool head on top.
[ Laughter ]
-Describe the shape of the head.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Cylinder --
Cylinder --
Like a cylinder head.
-Like, with the mask
or without the mask?
-Oh, with the mask.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah, mask head.
-And, like, describe
the back of the head.
-It's red and black?
-You're lying.
-What?
-Yeah.
He's got a little, "Vloop!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wait, is that The Rock?
-Yes, it's The Rock.
-Is that The Rock --
-The Rock on a rock.
-Wait, you've got
to give that to me.
My husband's working
with him right now.
This will be his, like,
really creepy star gift.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to give it to him
and tell him that Ryan
hand-painted it for him.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
I'm so mad you got that.
All right.
-Oh, wait, I have to put this
back in the box, right?
-Let's do one more.
Yeah, I can take it.
Here, I'll give this to my wife.
[ Laughter ]
She loves "The Wizard of Oz."
Here you go.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, whoa! I just activated
the cereal. Okay.
We have -- Someone has to eat
this before the time's up.
-Oh, wait, that's so fun.
-All right, we'll do
one more last one.
-Wait.
[ Audience shouting
indistinctly ]
Whew, this is so light.
Whoa, it's the helium
in this thing.
-Oh, I just heard it.
It was very heavy.
You lied already.
Whew!
-Okay.
♪♪
Oh, that's real!
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if you're going to
get this pop culture reference.
[ Laughter ]
I think that's Devon Sawa.
Um...
-Oh. Oh, is it?
[ Laughter ]
Then I probably know
exactly what it is.
-It's "J-14."
-"J-14."
-Mm-hmm, with a --
Oh, God.
It's like a trough of --
-I don't --
-No, like a pedestal,
like, what do you --
Like a bird bath, I guess,
of actual chili.
-All right. Those are the first
two things I understood
that you said. All right.
Bird bath and chili, all right.
Now we're on my level.
-Devon Sawa, I told you.
You don't remember Devon Sawa?
-Devon Sawa is my best roommate.
-He was like a teen dream.
-He was my favorite. What?
-I mean, I think
it's Devon Sawa.
Maybe I'm the old one.
I don't know.
Okay, and then there's, like,
a bird bath of fresh chili
with freshly grated cheese
and chives and sour cream,
and then there's a bird.
-Stop. Stop talking. Stop.
-There's a bird...
-Stop! Stop talking!
-...with green juice.
-Stop talking!
Stop it right now!
-With a Mohawk.
-'Cause let me
tell you something!
I would have smelled chili,
if chili was out of that box.
So -- I'm a detective.
Blake Lively, you lie!
-Well, let me start
with the chili first.
[ Laughter ]
-What? Are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What? I didn't win.
-Yes, because it was chili --
-Oh, 'cause I did lie.
Yeah, I did lie.
-I have no idea.
Blake Lively, everyone,
is the win--